un rendez vous à noter dans vos agendas
match de football caritatif sera
organisé le 26 septembre prochain à la
celle saint cloud l'événement réunira
des stars et les fonds seront reversés
au profit des enfants de l'association
sos gazelles pour nous parler de ce
rendez vous avec nous via écran
interposé véronique chaplin
organisatrice de cet événement bonjour
bonjour alors pourquoi vous organisez ce
match à la celle saint cloud véronique
est bien dans la continuité du type
break et des rassemblements sportifs de
haut niveau caritatif
j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer le
président du csc loi qui lui même joueur
de foot et qui nous a proposé à
l'occasion d'une rencontre contre le
variété club d'intégrer des joueurs sos
gazelle souvent des anciens du psg mais
d'autres clubs
donc les joueurs du cs ces lois et les
joueurs dassault est gazelles pour jouer
contre le variété club et l'ensemble des
bénéfices de cette journée avec
également des enchères seront reversés
pour les enfants de sos cazelles d'où
vous est venue l'idée
véronique et bien en fait c'est en
discutant avec mickaël lui au président
du cs six lois de dire que outre ss
gazelle organiser une à deux fois par an
des événements mais lorsqu'on peut être
co organisateur et qu'on a la chance de
rencontrer des gens qui également à vide
des stars pour lui c'était l'occasion de
nous rendre la pareille de nous soutenir
de nous aider et quand il m'a sollicité
m'a demandé est ce que vous voulez faire
partie du club de foot lui qui non
seulement on va intégrer le match de
foot mais on va aller plus loin on va
faire un brin comme le tiebreak une
journée enchères une journée festive
on va inviter également des
personnalités alors vous organisé depuis
près de 27 ans le tiebreak sur les golfs
des yvelines vous avez dû l'annuler
cette année à cause du coc vide 19
forcément évidemment compliqué pour vous
ça a été tiré parce que ça fait 28 ans
qu'on organise ce type break roland
garros qui est lié au tournoi de roland
garros pendant les qualifs et cette
année alors que tout était sous contrôle
que nous parthenay
fidèle nos sportifs no parano école
était prêt et surtout on avait choisir
sublime golf le golf par robert hersant
il a fallu tout annuler alors dans notre
malheur on a beaucoup de chance et nos
partenaires sont fidèles et en plus de
ce match de foot qui annule la veille de
roland-garros cette année roland garros
démarre le 27 septembre
on a décidé de maintenir le tibet sur le
magnifique golder sens avec l'ensemble
des partenaires ce sera mardi 1er
décembre
et même s'il fait un peu froid le thème
du père noël les enfants et c'est donc
la fête sera tout aussi belle quel est
le concept du tibre est que justement il
ya une partie de golf avec des stars
mais également les activités pour les
enfants je crois exactement l'idée c'est
de lier trois mondes le monde des
enfants et des jeunes le monde des
entreprises beaucoup de pme de chefs
d'entreprise et le monde des sportifs
donc il ya deux choses en parallèle il
ya une compétition amicale de golf avec
héros de golf des joueurs de roland
garros des sportifs de haut niveau et de
chefs d'entreprises
et à côté de ça il ya des ateliers
multisports et des olympiades avec la
boxe le foot le rugby l'athlétisme à
chaque fois des champions qui en cas d
école des yvelines par rapport à ce
match de football est ce que les
sportifs ont répondu présent tout de
suite
les célébrités ont répondu présent tout
à fait j'étais très étonné parce que je
me suis dit qu septembre octobre à
l'aide des mois très chargé et quand on
a appelé nos amis ça soit patrick mboma
kambouaré à la roche amara simba patrice
loko philippe ndioro ils ont tous dit
oui spontanément et quand j'ai appelé
défilent également ce qui veut dire
qu'il ya un vrai attachement ssd les
gens se libère et ça ça fait plaisir
alors les fonds sont reversés aux
enfants des sceaux s gazelles est ce
qu'on peut nous en dire un peu plus
alors en fait on va faire à la fois une
tombola
il y aura une tombola avec des jeux à
gagner est donc là ça sera pour un 16
gazelle et on va faire ce qu'on fait
traditionnellement au tiebreak on est en
train de récolter des maillots de foot
collector des maillots de rugby des
raquettes de tennis
et on va le signer toussaint bien sûr et
on va les vendre aux enchères comme on
fait d'habitude au tiebreak voilà donc
s'il ya des gens passionnés par des
parts des objets collectors qui n'hésite
pas voilà est ce que tout le monde peut
suivre cette rencontre à ce que
quelqu'un d'extérieur peut venir voir ce
match tout à fait alors l'idée c'est
justement comme c'est au sein du csc loi
c'est d'inviter le plus grand nombre et
le public peut venir ils auront la
chance de en plus d'être avec ses stars
et puis de partager un moment sympa
parce qu'en fait les jeunes du csc loi
vont également jouer avec ses stars donc
ça va être une grande fête c'est festif
l'entrée sera gratuite et bien
évidemment tous les gens désirent line
et même les amis des yvelinois peuvent
venir au csc loi à 15h le samedi 26
septembre pour s'amuser puis pour
soutenir la cause aussi est-ce qu'il ya
intérêt sportif ou c'est plutôt une
ambiance bon enfant
alors c'est avant tout une ambiance
bonne enfant si le plaisir pour les
stars de se retrouver pour les
partenaires de voir si les champions
pour les stars de faire une belle oeuvre
pour les enfants parce que sayid y
tiennent ils veulent toujours rendre ce
qu'ils ont reçus mais derrière moi je
pense que peut-être un peu de repérage
de futurs champions en vue je pense
qu'il ya des footballeurs qui sont
reconvertis là dedans et qui auront un
oeil a droit on peut être pérenne aux
futurs champions de demain
mais est ce que les stars comme patrick
mboma voudront perdre sur cette
rencontre
ce qu'ils pourront perdre patrick mboma
ne voudra pas perdre quand on est
champion reste champion que la soie les
canuts variété ou les
les footballeurs de sos gazelle ils sont
très potes en dehors du terrain mais dès
que le le le lancement du match et
démarrer ils vont jouer à fond pour être
fasse attention de pas se blesser quand
même parce que il reste des champions
ils ont cet esprit de la gagne de la
discipline et de l'effort jazeera
également le tiebreak le 2 décembre je
le précise dans un golf un exactement
elysées en parallèle c'est la même chose
il joue au golf pour s'amuser mais à
partir du moment où je vous la compet
avec le titre de champion je peux vous
dire qu'ils lâchent rien
merci à vous et véronique chapin d'être
intervenu dans cette émission je
rappelle la date de ce match caritatif
ce sera le 26 septembre à la celle saint
cloud